[Musica]
ciao e benvenuto
oggi stiamo andando via dal castello
purtroppo è stato bellissimo stare in
questo castello anche se a volte c'era
qualcosa di strano se non avete visto
gli altri episodi andate poi a vederlo
ora stiamo in direzione parco dei mostri
non vediamo l'ora di vedere tutti molto
in questa è la nostra challenge di oggi
pronti filosa franto salutare e fresca
novità la storia
ciao ragazzi siamo al sacro bosco il
parco dei mostri
questa è la nostra mamma ora ve la
facciamo vedere abbiamo trovato il primo
mostro
eccolo quando vediamo tutti mostri che
dovremo trovare guardate allora noi
siamo qua
questo è il primo mostro che si chiama
fratello l'auto e ora andiamo a vedere
tutti gli altri mostri la fine del video
scriveteci quale quello che mi è
piaciuto di più tra questi mostri anche
noi viviamo il nostro preferito è
bellissimo
[Musica]
da champions
siamo vicini alla tartaruga quand a
secco sono tartaruga gigante
[Musica]
benzema
[Applauso]
[Musica]
guardate questa causa
o così sembra che stia per crollare
proviamo ad entrare dentro e vediamo
come
[Musica]
e stranissimo sembra di essere spinti
verso il passo nella morte
tutto questo rumore è un canto vieni tra
il canto dei mostri o delle sirene poi
ho sentite andiamo verso il suono del
canto vediamo che ai mostri troviamo sì
[Musica]
questo è l'orco
[Applauso]
[Musica]
le unità
forse è meglio se sei un po attenta ma
nella bocca dell'orco
[Musica]
fa un po impressione permesso tempo di
eco
benissimo ma principato data d'uscita
loro ruolo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e stato questo elefante del grande e più
bello marcato costo invece è entrato
guardate che bella idea
[Musica]
dove il cane riuscite a vederlo qua
stai cerbero il cane a tre teste come in
harry potter puffi cinque stati
[Musica]
portate questo sembra l'apertura della
camera dei segreti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
chissà se a un'apertura sigaretta che
portavo con che parte anche questa e
dall'altra parte c'è da scoprire
e così qua ci siamo seduti qua nella
panchina del sacro bosco è bellissimo ma
dimmi un po qual era il tuo mostro
scultura preferito miei mostri preferiti
erano l'orco bellissimo davvero
e poi la donna dormiente anche se non
era un vero e proprio mostro però la
scultura era bellissima che c'era il
cane che c'era il cagnolino al fianco
sia le mie preferite erano un orco lo
stesso bellissimo poi il drago nero e la
sirena mi piace e le vostre preferite
qual'erano scrivetelo nei commenti
e ora continuiamo il nostro viaggio
stanotte arriveremo in un altro posto in
cui dormire mo e vi faremo vedere la
prossima tappa quindi pronti dal parco
dei mostri siamo scesi ancora funzioni
in macchina ora siamo in abruzzo
qua c'è vitale e una vita
questa è l'entrata è grandissima letto
tv mite anche di fare lo ammetto quasi
del cibo che bisogna
ondra abitare le cose che lo fa sparire
niente che so se c'è dell'altro cibo
così anna non c'è proprio niente anche
preoccupare perché ero più tardi la cosa
più bella di questa stanza e che c'è la
vista sul mare su un bellissimo terrazzo
se anche il tramonto
che relax
ora torniamo ad esplorare dentro cosa
stai facendo
che cosa hai detto cosa ho trovato sono
bio adesso lo sai che le cose nei frega
degli hotel costano tantissimo e quindi
lasciano non è giusto però insistono a
mangiare questa è un'altra finestra che
lo abbiamo visto il bagno ma quale sarà
la nostra prossima tappa la nostra
prossima challenge non c'è nessuna
lettera abbiamo seguito la mappa se
siamo arrivati qua ma dobbiamo aspettare
la prossima lettera per capire qual è la
prossima alle risse con un forte qua era
stata danneggiata mattina voi lasciate
un mi piace sopportarsi infortunio nella
prossima challenge e ora vi lasciamo 4
castellinesi di cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
[Musica]